so harper's law will see anyone guilty
of causing the deficit of an emergency
worker um face a life sentence in prison
so basically anybody who
takes the life of one of our protectors
that's paramedics nurses doctors
prisoners at prison officers
um
and police officers then you know
they're they'll get an adequate sentence
and i think that that's something that
resonates with a lot of the public now
they they're starting to see that
actually what's in place already isn't
good enough um and we need to change
that so um you know i'm pleased to get
harpers or to this point where we're
making a difference
this has been um a lot of work for you
and the campaign is how important is it
that you've you've been successful
it's incredibly important um it's been a
very long and hard journey to get to
this point and you know i started
this campaign with andy fiddler and
i remember sitting in the garden having
a conversation about why we needed to do
this
and it started with a sense of
feeling of injustice feeling of anger
and and this isn't right and and
something needs to change um and
throughout this process i've i've
received an immense amount of support
from the public and you know those close
to me but also strangers
who who want something different for our
country and i think we want to look at
our laws and be proud of it and to be
able to say yeah that's you know that's
what should be happening um and so
to reach this point with harper's law
i'm really proud of all the work that
we've we've done
um this will allow um people who do kill
emergency workers to be get longer
sentences do you hope that it will also
deter people from from taking the lives
of those emergency workers i think it
sends a message to those who
lead those sorts of lives who commit
crimes who have no
remorse for for taking innocent people's
lives away and it will tell them that we
won't stand for this um
and just because you know
you are able to do these horrendous
crimes doesn't mean that you're going to
get away with it and i think it sends a
message to to people like that and their
families and their
communities that live this way that you
know you may you may commit the act but
it won't be tolerated
sadly andrew's not with us anymore but
the the men and women who work with on a
daily basis they're out there today
doing the same job that he did
how do you think they'll feel about this
new law
i know a lot of andrew's colleagues and
people in the emergency work emergency
services
feel a sense of
justice has you know maybe this will
create some justice obviously
in andrew's situation it's too late for
that um and that's something that i will
have to live with but i know that they
feel like they're being looked out for
um because because that's what it is
it's protecting our protectors it's
something that we owe them um and they
go out every day and put themselves in
danger to protect the innocent people
and it can only be good for everybody
you know for everyone who leaves a um a
lawful life it can only be a good thing
and i think the majority of people can
see that